heavily in negatively our relationship
and the attitude in warrenton was right
cool and this coolness was visible in
the reluctance to accept Ukraine to
participate in Prague NATO summit later
in 2003 in 2003 when Ukraine has decided
to send its Italian to Kuwait in the
wake of the operation in Iraq it was a
good sign received positively in
Washington and especially when Ukraine
has decided to send its contingent to
derive so the the relationship has
changed the attitude of Washington
changed to a mo
I
how are you
religion college
shoulder
oh and the people
Oh
is it again
I
I I still do refer to the example of
other countries including this one how
closely the politicians are being
connected to the people and how closely
they are reflecting the moons of the
society in Ukraine you may distinguish
the politicians there is only one you
know people of Ukraine is no
consolidated but at the same time you
have different politicians for example
which ma and his regime are very
unpopular deeply and this has been
resulted in the elections recent
parliamentary elections when those who
were affiliated with kuchma have
received the least support from the
population from the people at the same
time the the alternative political
forces like for example our Ukraine
which has been created to two months
before the elections has received the
highest ever in Ukraine's history
support from from the people so that
means that the aspirations of Ukrainian
people were on the part of the parties
who where and are still are they
alternative to the current regime so in
this I see more or less than the
response and the ties between the people
the majority of people and the
politicians representing the Opposition
in Ukraine
hey
to us
either I think there are two two parts
of this decision first is what is
concerned with the Democratic procedures
and and we have them I think were
established important in terms of
elections and voting and parliamentarian
regulations and so on the other part the
skull is connected with with the ability
of citizens are to express their views
during the curve an in parliamentary
term and this is not self of this
important why because a million
important are very much concentrated it
needs these influential TV stations and
congratulations and major newspapers the
concentrated that doesn't mean that they
belong to certain party but there's a
certain kind of media our environment
and one sir once certain idea is being
circulated among this million in run it
might be very influential whether it is
for the certain point people Atlanta is
or against for example
media created the bigger success of SSD
three years ago and now the same in
media are telling them that once again
you want to make this post or more
complicated this is not done be
necessary that we have how the course
and free agent all the times we have
this now unfortunately
reduce our last speaker I once again
would like to remind everyone that the
reason that we were able to put together
such an interest in meaningless because
there was not only a confluence of
intellectuals that wanted to discuss
these issues but there were institutions
that were interested in sponsoring and
taking part of it representatives of
those institutions that are in the
audience today I thank you very much and
I would like to say again who or what
those institutions are you training
institute of america ukrainian free
academy in America you creating a
congress committee of America we perish
and Shengo scientific society the
self-reliance federal credit union of
New York propulsion Erica Ukrainian
cooperation initiative which is financed
by USAID by arm of the US government the
Pacific Institute the WK begins
nokia the best small foundation in new
york city fiscal condition the first
security Federal Savings Bank of Chicago
all of you helped us put this together
and we thank you very much